hey baby hey baby you know it's me
yeah i'm just calling in checking out
see what's good
what's happening with you baby listen
baby hey are you ready for this
oh hell yeah look i'm a little bit
lonely
i don't know you don't think and i
noticed your instagram has been lacking
a lot of bikini pics lately
and i've been kind of needing something
to jack off you know what i'm saying
i just wonder if you could post up real
quick and get some of them good
keen shots you know what i'm saying hell
yeah baby keep in touch baby
all right see you later baby do you
think you're a baby
we're in a civil rights movement the
bikini pics are we're going to put a pin
in that for a little while i think
but baby baby baby baby baby
that man we took a shot every time he
would have said baby we would have
fucking died
what actually like creole like louisiana
kind of you feel like that person's
related to you something
no fuck off absolutely not but that is
that's the realest reaction i've ever
gotten free
fuck off to you do you know
fuck you so stupid i love i
love just some real fucking it's just
like i'm not playing with you right now
i love him when someone's just like fuck
you do you know you were supplying
jackoff picks in the world like this i
don't know
i think that people do jerk off to my
feet sometimes which is wild
some get people are into fake boobs i
wonder if this man knows that pornhub is
a thing like he doesn't i know
he doesn't have to wait up on you i
think what i'm realizing about guys and
their jerking off is they want to jerk
off to people they know
it's nice and you two are best friends
yeah we're very close you two are like
oh you have
you do secret santas what do you guys do
i think it's weird when you do
follow someone on instagram i do think
you start to think you're facetiming
with them
i i've i've run into a couple people
lately that i have not seen in years but
i follow them on instagram i'm like hey
what's going on with your knee and
they're like
i'm like oh fuck i feel like we're
together and we're not
yeah i get why people feel this is
similar to that for sure yeah yeah yeah
we did some bikini pics for a while
remember that yeah you had all those
bathing suits you kept ordering yeah and
then benton
uh i was like god my ass looks amazing
and then he was like yeah i used the
filter to make your butt bigger
yes i love photoshopping a photo